[موسيقى]
داخل الجبال ونظام النهر المتعرج
خارج بلدة Cabarete مباشرة
هي واحدة من أكثر المشاهد الفريدة في البلاد ،
الفطر السحري ،
الوادي ذو الشكل الغريب ، يتم تقريبه من
الأعلى ورقيقًا في الأسفل مما يمنحه
مظهر غطاء الفطر بعد  على بعد
45 دقيقة بالسيارة من المدينة إلى مدخل الوادي ، يمكن
للزوار التنزه والسباحة
عبر الغابة قبل الوصول إلى
الفطر السحري على طول الطريق ، وهناك فرص كثيرة
للقفز على المنحدرات لبعض
الشلالات الأكثر إثارة في منطقة البحر الكاريبي بمجرد وصول الزوار إلى
الفطر السحري يمكنهم الانزلاق إلى أسفل  ما يقرب من 200
قدم في تيارات المياه العذبة أثناء
المشي لمسافات طويلة إلى عيش الغراب السحري ، سيصادف الزوار
الوديان
الشلالات الرائعة والتكوينات الصخرية المنحوتة بشكل جميل
[موسيقى]